esports hosts have
a type that's not a bad thing mind you
it makes sense to want to set a
consistent professional tone because
when it comes to show business
not everything can be controlled they
were getting passive they were giving up
a lot of front of the site room off
amazing
oh okay
well
i don't know what is going on
i hope you've enjoyed your dream hack
but it also makes sense to want to try
something
new something
stylish something
dangerous and building hosting and
streaming careers on those two
principles is exactly what rich campbell
did he leaned into the memes and spoke
his mind no matter what was on it i
decided to start drama with
rich campbell because one he's currently
relevant too because he is a dumb
i will respond when she also fills
category number one
yeah you can't get in here he's stupid
yeah
if the earth looks like this then i
ain't i was made by mitt is kiff his
sister is so hot giving me a kiss
are you watching right now emily
we only do this sometimes other times we
do really cool content like go outside
however it's those same chaotic impulses
that made rich so interesting in the
first place that eventually got him
fired from a gig that meant a lot to him
some of the stuff i say on stream is
probably not stuff that you would always
want to have somebody who's representing
uh
your game saying but instead of
wallowing in his own self-pity
he found a new direction and more
importantly a new inspiration
make like a tree oh my god
yeah
yeah dude and as a result two
communities one that was jaded and
looking for something new the other
waiting for recognition decided to join
rich
for a crazy ride
i like that i like that
not you you don't even know you stay
away from me so where exactly did rich
campbell come from how did spending time
homeless in new york inspire his life's
direction and why was getting
blackballed by blizzard may be the best
thing that ever happened to him he got
fired
he got fired
so if you find yourself recognizing rich
campbell
it could be for a variety of reasons
maybe you caught him on stage at an
event you watched why are you looking at
me like that what
he's looking at me very centrally
no i'm not sorry about him looking at
you or maybe his unique sense of style
left an impression or you might have
stumbled upon him more recently as his
stream exploded in popularity pretend to
use a solid shaker in your tongue you'll
taste salty wait you will yeah
wait do it do it do it like pretend to
use a chocolate sauce shaker in your
tongue need to like close my eyes or
anything yeah and stick your tongue out
and pretend to use his health shaker
but long before he was losing his [ __ ]
on camera and breaking the traditional
mold of an onstage personality rich
campbell was just a dude who loved video
games growing up in atlantic city rich
started playing video games at a young
age not knowing that his hobby would
later change his life
after finishing high school rich was
accepted into nyu's pre-med program but
when the financial crisis hit in 2008 it
turned everything upside down for him
rich's family home ended up in
foreclosure and he found himself unable
to pay rent and tuition
leaving him homeless so i ended up in
new york without a place to stay
for a couple years and i got plenty of
crazy good stories from that time
and i feel like it really kind of made
me a lot of who i am today even though
it was kind of you know in theory a
rough time i i i it ended up okay for me
but rich saw leaving nyu was
giving up and he had no interest in
being a quitter so with the help of some
friends and after couchsurfing for a
while he made his return but this time
with the intent to study narrative
strategies in video games
i was like you know what i've always
wanted to work on video games
who the [ __ ] knows what's gonna happen
i don't care about money
i'm gonna do what like i'm gonna do what
i like i've always loved video games
after finishing his program rich worked
as an instacart shopper and it was
around that time that he was presented
with the opportunity to join mlg
although back then by his own admission
he wasn't exactly
qualified i have an interview at mlg
with a guy named will who ended up
becoming a very good friend
and will is interviewing me and he
remembered me from the game center
because i had played starcraft against
him one time i'm wearing a suit he's
like hey do you know how to do this do
you know how to do this do you know how
to do that i'm like no i don't know how
to do any of this man and he goes you
know what you got the job
and sure enough the next day i am an
employee at mlg
despite his lack of technical skills
rich poured hours into learning every
aspect of production that he could but
his main goal was to become a caster and
by 2015 he got his first shot on the
desk at the grand finals for season 1 of
mlg pro rocket league after being asked
to stand in for chris puckett looking at
the shots on goal they're pretty even
uh it's just impressive play from both
teams very really impressive 15 shots
versus what 11 shots 15 versus 11.
that's the thing with luck
you have to
keep practicing so the time that you get
that lucky shot you don't pick up over
the next few years rich was given more
and more casting gigs and his style
really began to develop he was part
unbridled enthusiasm part unfettered
opinion and he was clearly always
enjoying himself who do you think's
gonna win mom
serious serious you think sirius is
gonna take the entire thing all right
mom i love you
okay
shut up kyle
[Laughter]
whether he was running an online d d
game in the mlg studio or working a
tournament for another scene altogether
rich's profile was on the rise and the
opportunities kept coming but he always
had a soft spot for one of the true og's
the one that immediately lined him up
with more work world of warcraft even as
giggs like the now defunct h1z1 league
came and went or as he took the stage in
some of dota's biggest tournaments in
2019
rich never forgot the impact that wow
had on his career after all beyond the
steady work it offered him it had also
introduced rich to some of his closest
friends our first guest on all craft
was this guy he would get maybe you know
maybe like 4 000 viewers and his name
was uh asthma gold i don't know if you
guys have heard of him
and
we did we did the episode
and
wait i kind of want to pull it up
and at the end of the episode he goes
boys what time next week but
unfortunately for rich the appeal of wow
really began to decline in 2020. 2018's
battle for azeroth expansion was near
universally panned for its borrowed
power systems and the time investment
required to maximize them for many it
was the worst expansion since warlords
of draenor since cataclysm or maybe ever
in the game's history and to make
matters worse blizzard seemed largely
disinterested in fans negative response
to bfa the wow community was on edge and
rich campbell was no exception take a
break richard you realize i was in a
great mood
and i played the game for five minutes
and i'm here
i don't need a break i need to uninstall
wow this is a game made for [ __ ] anyone
who's playing wicket look at you idiot
look at you you idiot why are you
playing this game you're
dumb [ __ ] you
you're on shakes you
aliens you dumb
why are you playing this
[ __ ]
you morons running around like ants in
bobby codex maze
not long after his explosive rant
rich got a call from blizzard
and the news
wasn't good as of june 2020 he was no
longer to be a part of future wow
broadcasts i'm no longer going to be a
part of the awc
it wasn't my choice i got the call uh
two or three days ago now if you went on
the world of warcraft twitch channel and
you randomly scrolled through chances
where you might bump into me to call
that and an honor doesn't even do it
justice i mean it was a dream come true
in the wake of his banishment rich
decided to move to texas with the goal
of making content alongside some of his
peers but he also decided on streaming
full-time after what six years
of being a commentator
i'm not one anymore
pull that band-aid off uh
i guess i'm a streamer now
which also means i'm now kind of an
idiot
streamers are so dumb
but even if he was downgraded to a dumb
streamer rich still had
big aspirations and in october he
announced the creation of one true king
a gaming organization that also included
asman gold s fan tips out and mizkiff
for rich otk was going to be a primary
focus and through it he was able to stay
connected to his friends
and to wow
even if he wasn't welcome on the
official blizzard broadcasts
the truth is gentlemen
that today
is no ordinary stream today
whoa
ladies and gentlemen the doors to castle
will not open themselves we need to
smack
the org was according to s fend part
media company part lifestyle brand but
it was also a way for the founders many
of whom had a past in wow to test the
waters outside of the game and to
potentially lessen their dependence on
it the decision was
well
incredibly well timed because after the
release of wow's newest expansion
shadowlands and a barrage of feedback
that blizzard had once again ignored
people started to wonder how bright the
future of the game might actually be
let's be honest
blizzard has completely dropped the ball
i love every philosophy the world of
warcraft team spouts and i absolutely
think that it's always in line with the
player experience but let's be honest
wow fans complaining about wow is pretty
much what always happens the difference
was that in 2021
the game was legitimately bad and if the
game itself wasn't bad enough blizzard
gave fans plenty of reasons to stop
supporting their content having already
lost his job with blizzard the effect
that this turmoil in wow had on rich's
career was
minimal he'd already dialed back his
streaming substantially to focus on
building otk and at the same time his
enthusiasm for wow had waned now i've
started to move away from the game not
all the way but i've started to move
away from the game
i still love it
but
you know i i think that uh some of the
things that we've tried to get change
probably won't happen
some some probably will despite the fact
that he was no longer hosting and that
his stream had taken a bit of a back
seat rich was still an entertainer he
just
needed a new stage and that's precisely
what he got with final fantasy 14. now
to be fair the game wasn't exactly
new it had a disastrously launched in
2010 and miraculously relaunched a few
years later although it remained largely
ignored but for many mmo fans rich's
decision to start streaming ff14 became
their best possible introduction to the
game oh yeah
[Applause]
dude i love this game stop hitting
gremlo do the thing grumble
do the thing hey do the thing do the
thing do this finger oh go go
go go
hey
hey
dude the dragoons are badass man
they're
badass man
holy [ __ ] dude that about settles it for
me there's something that i need to do
between his first ff14 stream in june of
2021 and the end of july rich campbell
had amassed an earth-shattering 25 000
subs in the months that followed some of
wow's biggest creators followed rich's
lead and it wasn't long before ff14
exploded in popularity as streamers and
wow die hards began dabbling rich worked
on completing hundreds of hours of main
story content he met up with friends
both old and new for in-game events
you gotta admit i look
good bro yeah if you're getting ready
for a child pageant what dude i'm a
magician i have a secret weapon go ahead
purple
now what do you think bro i came
prepared i think that your character
looks exactly like your parents live in
the trailer they're obsessed with elvis
and they dress their kid up that's five
years old like elvis and he gets pushed
around and bullied in school because of
it he also teamed up with them to
challenge some of the
[Laughter]
[Music]
man that was
and as he finally completed the
shadowbringers expansion and watched the
trailer for the upcoming end walker
he reflected on the fact that trying
something new and stepping outside his
comfort zone had once more led to
success
streaming this game
has changed my life forever
it's made me really really happy in ways
that i can't even
describe to you
rich campbell is proof that being
yourself and embracing change can
absolutely be a path forward
even if you're not exactly sure where it
leads you can't always control the
things that happen to you and no one is
invulnerable but you can choose how you
view those things and how you react
maybe rich could have ended up simply
working behind the scenes at otk and
pondering what could have been but
that's the thing about rich he isn't
really the type to just
let things happen to him instead he
breathed new life into himself and his
career and found strength from a
community that was pulling for him to
succeed obviously i i i there were a lot
of things going on in my life outside of
the game
from everything that you know you guys
might not remember but with with
everything that was going on with my
grandma
to
like breaking up with the girl who i
literally thought i was gonna get
married to and on those shitty days i
would go live and even if i wasn't
myself and i wasn't the best streamer
that i could be on those days you guys
were still there
and you took care of me and it's that
same community who continues to look to
rich to give them the same excitement
and unrestrained enthusiasm
that he's clearly
never lost now i can't imagine being
anything else
so thank you for letting me be what i
truly am a filthy sack of potatoes
and it cut to rich campbell
and he was literally
with just like this like
like viscerally sexual face just like
slowly like undoing his jacket and just
gyrating